>>> DOZENS OF FORMER REPUBLICAN
AND DEMOCRATIC OFFICIALS ARE
ANNOCING A NEW NATIONAL
POLITICAL THIRD PARTY CALLED
FORWARD.
IN AN OP-ED IN "THE WASHINGTON
POST," KEY MEMBERS WRITE THEIR
GOAL IS TO, QUOTE, BUILD A NEW
UNIFYING POLITICAL PARTY FOR THE
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS WHO WANT
TO MOVE PAST DIVISIVENESS AND
REJECT EXTREMISM.
OUR NEXT GUEST CO-WROTE THE
OP-ED, ANDREW YANG, FORMER
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE AND
CHRISTINE TODD WHITTEMAN, FORME
EPA LEADER.
THIS SO RARELY WORKS, SO WHY
WILL YOUR EFFORT WORK?
>> WE'RE IN A DIFFERENT TIME
NOW --
>> WELL, THE APPETITE --
>> GO AHEAD, CHRISTINE.
>> 50 -- OKAY.
WHEN YOU HAVE 50% OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SAYING THAT THEY
ARE REGISTERED INDEPENDENT OF
THE VOTERS OF REGISTERED VOTERS,
A VOTER INDEPENDENT, PEOPLE ARE
SICK AND TIRED OF WHAT THEY'RE
SEEING IN WASHINGTON AND THE
FACT THAT NOTHING MAJOR IS
GETTING DONE, IT IS FRUSTRATING.
WE HAVE BIG PROBLEMS AND WE WANT
TO SEE THEM RESOLVED.
WE NEED TO GET BACK TO A TIME
WHEN PEOPLE WILL TALK TO ONE
ANOTHER AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BRINGING PEOPLE TOGETHER, YOU
CAN KEEP YOUR PARTY LABEL,
REPUBLICAN, DEMOCRAT,
INDEPENDENT, DOESN'T MATTER, BUT
LET'S WORK TOGETHER TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS, LET'S ELECT THOSE
CANDIDATES WHO UNDERSTAND THAT
OUR ELECTORAL PROCESS IS THE
BEST IN THE WORLD, AND IT IS
SECURE.
AND WE NEED TO PICK THOSE
CANDIDATES WHO WILL SAY I'LL
WORK ACROSS THE AISLE BECAUSE I
WANT TO GET THINGS DONE.
>> SO, ANDREW, I WANT TO CORRECT
MYSELF, I SAID IT SO RARELY
WORKS, IT ACTUALLY NEVER WORKED,
TO BE CLEAR.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE OBSTACLES
HERE AND ONE MIGHT BE THE
POLICIES.
WHERE, BECAUSE, LOOK, THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCES,
POLICY-WISE, BETWEEN DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS.
WHAT ARE YOUR POLICIES GOING TO
BE THAT YOU CAN ACTUALLY AGREE
ON?
>> 62% OF AMERICANS NOW WANT A
THIRD PARTY.
A RECORD HIGH.
BECAUSE THEY CAN SEE THAT OUR
LEADERS AREN'T GETTING IT DONE.
WHEN YOU ASK ABOUT THE POLICY
GOALS, THE FACT IS THE MAJORITY
OF AMERICANS ACTUALLY AGREE ON
REALLY EVEN DIVISIVE ISSUES.
THE MOST DIVISIVE ISSUES OF THE
DAY LIKE ABORTION OR FIREARMS.
THERE IS ACTUALLY A COMMON SENSE
COALITION POSITION ON THESE
ISSUES AND JUST ABOUT EVERY
OTHER ISSUE UNDER THE SUN.
THE TAG LINE ON THE PARTY IS IT
IS NOT LEFT OR RIGHT, IT'S
FORWARD.
AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
THAT WOULD MEAN ON EACH ISSUE,
ACTUALLY THE POLICY BECOMES
PRETTY CLEAR WHEN YOU JUST ASK
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE FED UP BY
THE FACT THAT OUR LEADERS AREN'T
ACTUALLY RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS
OR THE WILL OF COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
>> SO, GOVERNOR, LET'S TAKE THAT
ISSUE.
GUNS, FOR INSTANCE, WHAT WOULD
THE POLICY BE THAT WOULD UNITE
ENOUGH PEOPLE TO MAKE A THIRD
PARTY SUCCESSFUL?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL,
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE DOING IS HOLDING A SERIES OF
LISTENING SESSIONS AROUND THE
COUNTRY TO TALK TO PEOPLE ABOUT
THAT VERY ISSUE.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
THAT YOU'VE SEEN IN EVERY POLL,
THE MAJORITY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE BELIEVE THERE SHOULD BE
SOME KINDS OF RESTRICTIONS, A
WAITING PERIOD.
THERE SHOULD BE A BACKGROUND
CHECK.
FRANKLY YOU DON'T WANT TO PUT
GUNS IN THE HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO
HAD NO TRAINING.
SO YOU -- PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE SOME TRAINING.
THOSE ARE THE ISSUES AROUND
WHICH WE CAN COALESCE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO SOLVE
EVERYTHING.
EVERYBODY'S PROBLEM AND YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO MAKE EVERYBODY
HAPPY.
AS YOU RIGHTLY POINT OUT, THERE
IS A GREAT DEAL OF DIVISION ON
SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
BUT WHEN YOU PEELING BACK THAT
ONION, IT IS AMAZING HOW MUCH
COMMON GROUND YOU CAN FIND AND
THEN YOU HAVE A POSITION FROM
WHICH TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
ONCE YOU START THAT PROCESS,
THERE IS GOING TO BE NO STOPPING
IT, QUITE FRANKLY.
>> ANDREW, GUNS, SOME AGREEMENT
IN CONGRESS RECENTLY ON THIS.
IS THAT NOT ENOUGH?
>> WELL, WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE
NEED FOR A POLITICAL
REALIGNMENT, THE FACT IS ABRAHAM
LINCOLN WON AS A THIRD PARTY
CANDIDATE WITH 39% OF THE VOTE.
WE CAN ALL TELL THAT THIS SYSTEM
IS FAILING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
88% OF AMERICANS THINK WE'RE ON
THE WRONG TRACK.
WE KNOW THAT POLARIZATION IS
JUST GETTING WORSE.
NOT BETTER.
LEADERS LIKE GOVERNOR WHITMAN
HAVE CROSSED PARTY LINES AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT TO SEE MORE OF.
THE FACT IS THIS TWO-PARTY
SYSTEM IS DISINTEGRATING BEFORE
OUR EYES, AND IS UNIQUELY
SUBJECT TO AUTHORITARIANISM.
IF YOU HAVE ONE OF THE TWO MAJOR
PARTIES HEAD DOWN A DARK PATH,
THE ENTIRE SYSTEM CAN GO DARK.
WHICH IS NOT THE WAY  OTHER
DEMOCRACIES FUNCTION AND NOT THE
WAY THE FOUNDING FATHERS
IMAGINED OUR COUNTRY FUNCTIONING
EITHER.
>> DIFFERENT PARTY SYSTEM,
THOUGH, RIGHT, OVER TIME.
GOVERNOR, HOW DO YOU GET PAST
THE ISSUE OF CLOSED PRIMARIES?
THAT IS KEY IF YOU'RE GOING TO
MAKE ANY SORT OF THIRD PARTY
SUCCESSFUL RATHER THAN JUST A
SPOILER.
>> NO, THAT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
IT IS A CHALLENGE, BUT IT HAS
HAPPENED BEFORE.
WE HAVE GOTTEN ON THE BALLOT.
I WAS PART OF A PROCESS, GOSH,
NOW MUST HAVE BEEN 12 YEARS AGO
WHERE WE WERE ABLE TO GET ON
BALLOT, ENOUGH STATES TO GET THE
REQUISITE VOTES AND THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE TO QUALIFY FOR
THE PRIMARY -- FOR THE DEBATES,
WHICH IS ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
WANT THE SANCTIONED DEBATES.
YOU CAN DO IT.
IT IS NOT GOING TO BE EASY.
WE'RE NOT SAYING THIS IS GOING
TO HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE'RE GOING TO
BE WORKING ON, BUT WE BELIEVE
AND REALLY KNOW THAT THERE IS A
HUNGER IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FOR SOMETHING ELSE BESIDES WHAT
THEY'RE BEING GIVEN.
WHAT WE'RE SAYING IS WE'LL GIVE
YOU AN ALTERNATIVE.
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED IN THIS,
GET IN TOUCH WITH US, GET IN
TOUCH WITH US NOW, LET US KNOW.
WE CAN BUILD COALITIONS IN YOUR
COMMUNITY, START TALKING ABOUT
THESE ISSUES, AND LET'S MOVE
FORWARD.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> ALL RIGHT, ANDREW, WHO IS
JOINING YOU?
ELON MUSK?
>> WE'RE GOING TO HAVE EXCITING
ANNOUNCEMENT ABOUT NEW PEOPLE
AND LEADERS FROM EVERY SECTOR OF
AMERICAN LIFE JOINING THE
FORWARD PARTY IN THE DAYS TO
COME.
62% OF AMERICANS WANT THIS.
THE PEOPLE WATCHING THIS RIGHT
NOW WANT THIS.
YOU JUST KEEP BEING TOLD YOU
CAN'T HAVE IT.
>> BUT I GOT TO ASK, IS ELON
MUSK ONE OF THOSE?
YOU SAID ELON MUSK?
ELON MUSK ONE OF THOSE?
>> I'M SORRY?
>> IS ELON MUSK ONE OF THOSE?
>> WELL, ELON MUSK DID SUPPORT
MY PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN AND
LET'S JUST SAY, AGAIN, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE SOME VERY EXCITING
ANNOUNCEMENTS IN THE DAYS TO
COME.
>> HE COULD BE A DIVISIVE
FIGURE.
GOVERNOR, WHO ELSE?
WHO ELSE DO YOU WANT TO SEE?
WHO ELSE IS WILLING TO DO THIS?
>> AS ANDREW SAID, WE'RE GOING
TO BE ANNOUNCING A LOT OF NAMES,
IMPRESSIVE NAMES, NAMES THAT
HAVE MONEY BEHIND THEM, NAMES
THAT HAVE POLITICAL EXPERIENCE
BEHIND THEM, NAMES THAT ARE
RESPECTED BY THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHAT WE CARE ABOUT.
WE CARE ABOUT PEOPLE WHO WILL
INSTILL CONFIDENCE IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND SO WE CAN
START TO MOVE FORWARD.
YOU'LL BE HEARING A LOT, YOU'LL
BE -- YOU'LL SEE THAT THIS
REALLY HAS SUBSTANCE.
THIS ISN'T JUST SOME FLY BY
NIGHT THING THAT WE THOUGHT OF
WOULDN'T THAT BE NICE TO DO.
THIS HAS BEEN CAREFULLY THOUGHT
OUT.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A CONVENTION
IN A YEAR, IN 2023 AND PULL THIS
TOGETHER, COME UP WITH A
PLATFORM AND BE ABLE TO HAVE
CANDIDATES THAT WILL AGREE WITH
THE FORWARD POSITION AND BE ON
THE BALLOT IN THE STATES.
WE HAVE THE INDIVIDUAL STATES
WITH DIFFERENT METHODS OF
WHETHER THEY ALLOW CANDIDATES ON
THE BALLOT, HOW YOU GET ON THE
BALLOT, WE'RE RESEARCHING AND
HAVE RESEARCHED ALL OF THAT.
THIS IS A VERY THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH THAT WE'RE TAKING.
AND YOU'RE GOING TO SEE, WE'LL
BE ON THE BALLOT.
WE'LL PRESENT CANDIDATES TO THE
PUBLIC.
>> I WILL TELL YOU, YOU PIQUED
SOME SKEPTICISM BUT ALSO I THINK
SOME CURIOSITY.
WE'LL BE WATCHING.
ANDREW YANG, GOVERNOR WHITMAN,
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.